hello and welcome to honest trailer
commentaries the show where we talk
about the show you hopefully just
watched going a little bit more detail
I'm Spence Jay Gilbert with me as always
Dan Morelle hello and we're gonna talk
about Batman Forever and if you stick
around we've got deleted scenes and a
little thing that we noticed that I
didn't make it into the final cut
yep Batman Forever dan yeah man I have a
feeling that there's we're being yelled
at right now a situation that spacejam
situation and we did the honest trailer
for Space Jam movie beloved by everyone
including us as children's children mid
nineties this seems to be the sweet spot
for a lot of our fans as far as growing
up with things Space Jam while still it
still holds a sentimental attachment for
many of us all right be Sean Bradley
yeah is not a very good know Batman
Forever I'm a huge Batman fan I was 12
years old in this movie came out making
impact on me too I have seen this movies
I can't tell you how many times I have
so much love and cinnamon Latasha Jim
Carrey I mean forever but mostly during
the mid-90s I mean I love laser tag the
movie inside of a laser tag arena Robin
was in it yeah cool Clarence again
objectively looking at it removing
yourself it's really not good stop
yelling it's not good just re-watch it
you heal this if you pause rewatch
Batman Forever and then comment but if
you're just yelling at us right now
remember it's really not and I hadn't
seen it in many many years and even I
stealing myself for how not good it was
even at times wasn't watching and going
like wow this is even not maybe it's
because we're just super old now because
it's so loud and great and that's so
grating on me now whereas before I guess
maybe like a loud cartoon with like you
know epilepsy lights flash a me was like
what I wanted but now it's just
screaming and brightness and loud noises
like stop just let it breathe for two
seconds yeah it is it
relentless yeah it is a relentless movie
throbbing with the pulse of the mid-90s
pulses and Joel Schumacher on a whole
bunch of Molly water and glow sticks in
a 808 it's like it's just too much this
relaxed I even remember this is a
glimmer of adulthood in my brain I
remember the first scene with to face
when he's like talking to the security
guard like stupid clueless like what
he's like going over the head again I
love this movie but I do remember for a
split second in my brain thinking okay
yeah but then I went back to being 12
and and yeah listen it's it's it's not
great every night as bad as Batman and
Robin which was covered yeah everything
else I have to say is covered in the
trailer itself so JT let's let's get
this goin so watch it this is for the
Justice League correct yeah Justice
League coming out right
from producer Tim Burton and replacement
director Joel Schumacher was he a Batman
movie that releases the 80s girl
yesterday right with the ecstasy soaked
fever jury of the mid-90s definitely the
worst movie I've seen thirty times
forever probably see missing funds the
story the story mr. Burton there the
story is it depends it's one of us
depends on how you talk to version
either he said I don't really want to
make another Batman movie or Warner
Brothers said you took it in a really
weird place with the last with Batman
Returns so we're gonna like that third
missing script or no there's a missing
fourth one there's one there was one
there's gonna be actor Batman and Robin
I think it's called Batman sorry I'm
with the Scarecrow and I think
supposedly they had Jack Nicholson lined
and like a dream a dream sequence to be
the Joker again yeah I don't know no
need to drag him through the mud after
Batman right exactly ask you come
continue after human cure song Tim
Burton Batman looks like on the
mainstream then put too much kinky stuff
in the sequel to sell kids toys Warner
Brothers pictures Schumacher as the
pariah a director to push the franchise
in a more family-friendly direction puka
shells with a tuxedo jacket drive to I
think they record that line just for
McDonald's by the way that wasn't made
good for all the toys that it's on
Batman Returns direct drive through
product placement yeah I remember it in
the ads for McDonald's that mine was in
the McDonald's ads so I feel like that
was corporate a lien but I agree Joel
Schumacher he does look like the guy
that would be like at a seaside Cabana
mm-hmm renting new equipment but like
would invite you to a weird after-hours
party that you're not really sure if you
should go yeah he's the guy Julian
Assange
sends out of the embassy to go buy weed
all right it's true Dennis Miller joke
of you
yeah Julius I did go buy him some weak
references speaking of 96 meet Val
Kilmer's unique take on Batman he's not
weird like Keaton charming like Clooney
intimidating like Bale swole like
athletic or emotional like a human but
he does contribute one major unique
trait to the Batman legacy his mouth is
always open now my guess is cuz it's
hard to breathe through your nose and
the thing that then just said no his
mouth is open when he's Bruce Wayne -
just a mouth breather as bugs I guess
it's one way to catch him said one -
that animation ace - faith read half the
time it's a real weakness but there's
also the ones he wearing Riddler Jim
Carrey at the height of his powers
brings the same manic energy he brings
to his other roles as Ron's - actors try
to one-up each other on camera while the
real drama was apparently going down off
screen he got up and hugged me and said
I hate you we cut there for some reason
but there was a he goes on to say Tommy
Lee Jones - Jim Carrey says I cannot
sanction your buffoonery I know I love
that line that was I haven't seen the
final final cut it's a great line it's
just like there's no more you need to
say after I hate you but I'm saying the
words just weird it's kind of confusing
cannot says if there were sanctioned
buffoonery yes that Tommy Lee Jones
would approve whose buffoonery would
Tommy Lee Jones buffoonery regulatory
agency does Tommy Lee Jones trust is
there like I feel like he's sanctioned
Joe Pantoliano knows buffoonery and the
fugitive yeah that seems sanctioned he's
generally not into movies with a lot of
buffoonery
No No so yeah that that that phrase I
think I'd a lot of play this week of
just unsanctioned buffoon I cannot
sanction your let's keep going yeah
thrill as Batman faces his greatest
danger yet the only thing that could
actually stop him for good
a therapist dr. chase meridian takes her
place alongside Vicki Bale as the latest
bad girl friend you'll never hear from
again totally forgot about breaking
commitments raw yeah and she's not using
either of them because all she does is
perv out on a stranger in a rubber suit
Thursday you are interesting well I wish
I could say that my interest in you was
purely professional so she's also dating
Bruce Wayne and she also first of all
what's she imagining the Batman body cuz
like that body or was she imagining like
the Scimitar rubber was he molded to his
body his specification but it wasn't
because we saw him and he's nuts we was
so when she says she was imagining his
body like was it the Batman body that
she looks like you know it's like
because of stuff in your bra like Batman
when he's designing these things like
well give me an extra app here make the
pecs pop a little bit why not those
nipples on there she also has a scene
where she basically dumps Bruce Wayne
for a boy Acrobat Robin because she sees
Robin she's like basically is like I
don't think it's gonna work out between
you and me she implies that she's gonna
go leave him to go hit on Robin after
the show it's very strange that they
mean she's a very qualified character
because doctor she's a third boxer she's
like snappy but man she just she's melts
in Batman's hands yeah they really
didn't give her anything to do in that
movie now it was very unfortunate when
you think about it Nicole Kidman's is 95
so she was kind of on her way up
right even still yeah come on Joel come
on Joel come on Akiva the great name
dr. chase meridian
it's like a Bond girl it is that she
then her character was like a Bond girl
so maybe that's what they had in mind
was let's just write a bond because like
Denis Richard did everything during this
movie is like this deep she had a lot of
credit yeah except for Batman yeah he
comes experience the bad family grow
bigger with Chris O'Donnell's Robin
who's lame origin story of the Robin
name that flew in like around is still
better than the Dark Knight Rises a cool
teen complete with cool motorcycle and
leather jacket giant 90s cool guy
arranged we all had something no one
will ever make cool that was largely
karate why was this yeah because this
was Alfred being like maybe I will
reveal all of our secrets to this oh
that's right cuz he did the Acrobat
thing and swung into those silver closet
pantry back he did that so maybe this
teenager should be sent out on the
streets to via punch crime yes I was
just thinking of the fact that if you're
gonna hide the Batcave somewhere
wouldn't you want to hide it in a room
where thieves would not want to enter
like why would you hide it in the silver
closet which is the first place of the
thieves are gonna go like the bathroom
or you know like the spare bedroom the
Batcave is broken into twice this thing
once they get inside is probably the
deleted scenes it's a very quiet early
Siri voice going and trued alert
intruder alert intruder alert
it's really the least secure Batcave of
all seven movies well and when you when
you and when you break in there's a
mechanism that brings the Batmobile up
out of the ground for you criminal steal
this too like no the battle you should
go down into the ground he's also able
to go joyriding in the Batmobile
after like your reward for breaking in
is you win a car not just a car yeah the
Batmobile
yeah fun though cool-looking yeah sure
all right keep going to things you don't
think about with your 12 now so witness
the beginning of the end of the original
back quadrilogy that put nipples on the
Batsuit launched akiva goldsman x'
career and cut out and st. so plot the
giant fat all the crazy things dad's
three thirty mean qualities the thumbs
up give the epic seal song and the fact
that no matter what you have to say it's
not as big as Batman and Robin never
leave the cave without starring hello
reddit I am accurate artist out well
does a lot of those elephants tarnished
Jim Carrey's the movie doctor girl for a
surrogate or a dull top secret plug for
this yes though her Michael's craziest
laser tag arena the Batman yeah guy
[Music]
what's that girl that may feel that oh
well that's probably our stupidest dog
good job Robert look it pause that real
quick anyone notice two faces layer all
new barks art is facing one direction
they're to rearrange the furniture when
he turns around it's fine JT's chicken
is fine
Robert hole T we give him a lot of
credit on the show but I mean just look
at that like that's it's he got like the
smoke effects he got the green like this
is why people watch commentaries I'm
sure does compliment Robert but Robert
dog or a horn Robert does great work
it's great that looks just like the
movies great he's fast he never sleeps
he's a nice guy nice good thing to say
about Robert hoping good job Robert yeah
yeah two-faced what I wonder which way
would stand when he decided which way
the lair was gonna go is it right
Geographic I like to imagine when he's
done in there he just slowly backs out
of the room like when you see the Queen
yeah you have two assistants one of whom
is drew Barrymore and Debi Mazar is the
other one was in Entourage
yeah amongst other things right she was
Vincent chases agent I don't know why
I'm sorry that that's the only role I
can think Debi Mazar
it's done many other great things yeah
yeah so that was Batman Forever that was
Batman Forever but it wasn't everything
we had to say about it I imagine we have
some deleted scenes that we will be
quiet for seasons rapid with a risky new
take on the Caped Crusader he sucks at
his job now watch as he lets these
acrobats die
let's to face free to roam the city
let's this kid sneaked into the Batcave
let's this clearly insane person work at
his company let's these super villains
walk right up to his front door and lets
them easily blow up the Batcave I mean
come on
I put extra locks in the door when I got
a PlayStation shouldn't a billionaire
have more security than a voice quietly
saying intruder alert starring Batman
for one movie I spat I'm your
huckleberry
like that Mart again pink skulls that
well hey that's not Billy Dee Williams
unsanctioned buffoonery Matthew let's go
yes
Joker still not as weird as being
married to Tom Cruise like white you
know with that right Gotham should be
buzzed yeah you can kind of see it there
I want to have a whole spin off about
whoever builds the enormous gargoyles
that are like the size of entire
skyscrapers in this version of Gotham
yeah they're the most wasteful public
works projects I've ever seen they
really and truly are yeah it's like
let's do like a greco-roman like discus
guy but now we'll make it besides of the
World Trade Center how much is it kind
of caused is are there people in it
that's al it's a very crowded urban
landscape you're wasting city blocks of
them on like buff men just like that you
can put like a subway track down his arm
I don't know maybe that's Bruce Wayne's
philanthropy is just putting people to
work like carrying stone from Egypt just
building monuments to maybe so I don't
know it's so it's a pretty weird Gotham
in this movie yeah it is
it's like present-day by way of 1990 by
way of the future I think we have a
other titles and more tags yeah so mr.
nygma what's on your mind precisely
what's on our minds worst shark tank
I don't know about you do you like the
circus
why are you thinking Turkish those
wrinkly bothered me since I was 12 it
was just mean but it's also true he has
a lisp randomly for that line yeah no
I'm not making nothing for people list
it's just strange that he says do you
like the third it's just that was this
character that's fine it's just for one
line in one line only Bruce Wayne had a
strange effect to the speech yeah
they're a resident they yeah I don't
know it's like manat strange in the
sense of like itself was strange but
strange in the sense that like it's for
one sentence in the entire movie and
then right well I might want to take
that again yeah but maybe the fibers
from his turtleneck got his teeth he
does have old man pants in one scene we
were looking at a cut big khakis that
was the decade the biggest khakis and
then there was one other thing I think
we have an image of it that we our
editor found post a completion of be
honest trailer says too late do anything
about it awesome but if you pause and
look that is none other than Jon Favreau
and that be Hogan as part of a Bruce
Wayne security Jay to enhance enhance
can you you can't damn it hello okay
well take it he's gonna try so if we had
noticed that we would have done
something about that two-timing happy
Hogan or got fired from Wayne core and
ended up with Tony Stark like what a
weird typecast or just weird coincidence
I walks behind the Sicilian CEO that is
a wow that's crazy I never knew Jon
Favreau's me neither I mean that's nuts
I wish we'd known that a week and a half
ago me too a new oh you guys have you in
hey always enhanced JT enhance yeah what
do you know showed up on the wrong day
when you're shooting swingers I have a
theory
yeah that is happy Hogan and that is
corporate espionage he's a sneaky spy
that's what it is this is the Schumacher
Batman movies and the end
see you connected it's a game theory
that's another video good stuff yeah
that I wish we knew about that earlier
but yes there is a definite conspiracy
theory video to be made about that there
is someone else do it for us I don't get
on it yeah thank you for Matt bet if
you're doing anyway so that's Batman
Forever next week I think it's a movie
that people will be much more unanimous
about there if I'm if I'm good
correct right it's a movie from this
year yep and it'll make you feel things
it'll make you feel things and you might
not know how to express them mm-hmm but
we do what we do we know exactly how yep
I'm Demerol I'm Spencer J Gilbert see
you next week for honest trailer
commentaries
[Music]
you